de blanchemaison merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france alors la pac
certes elle encore à quelque chose
aujourd'hui la pac c'est un élément tout
à fait stratégique à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
d'ailleurs le général de gaulle ne s'y
était pas trompé puisque en 1965 il
avait fait la politique de la chaise
vide c'est à dire que la france n'avait
pas siéger dans les instances de
décision de l'union européenne pour
obliger nos cinq partenaires de l'époque
à passer à une véritable politique
agricole commune intégrée donc l'origine
et est effectivement historique alors
que permettait sûr sur le plan
stratégique cette politique agricole
tant mieux intégrés et bien elle a
permis tout simplement de rendre l'union
européenne
auto suffisante sur le plan
agroalimentaire et non seulement auto
suffisante mais avec une capacité
d'exportation très importante puisque
l'union européenne exporte beaucoup et
la france parmi ses états membres est
l'un de ceux qui exportent plus en
matière agroalimentaire
donc c'est le rôle que joue la politique
agricole commune seule politique
sectorielle véritablement intégré à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne et qui
a joué plusieurs rôles naturellement ce
rôle aujourd'hui évoluer doit évoluer
puisque l'objectif de l'autosuffisance
alimentaire de la modernisation de
l'agriculture a été a été le très
largement atteint et tout cela ne coûte
il pas trop cher finalement le cadre
financier a été fixé en juillet par les
chefs d'état de gouvernement et vous
avez un chiffre tout à l'heure 386
milliards d'euros pour 7 en 2021 et 2027
et ceci représente à peu près la même
somme que pour les sept années
précédentes la même somme puisque si
l'on tient compte de la sortie du
royaume-uni qui ne participe plus à la
politique agricole commune
et qui va avoir à monter des dispositifs
dead ces agriculteurs parce que tous les
pays ont des dispositifs à leurs
agriculteurs et bien le royaume-uni est
en partie ce qu'il touchait va se
répartir entre les autres et amant et
les principaux bénéficiaires sont
premièrement la france deuxièmement
l'allemagne troisièmement l'espagne 4e
en l'italie est d'ailleurs le royaume
uni entre parenthèses était le sixième
bénéficier donc ça ne va faire une
économie de ce côté et par conséquent un
petit bonus à répartir alors la france
là dessus touche donc une la part du
lion en réalité depuis le début parce
qu'elle a su s'adapter aux différentes
évolutions de la politique agricole
commune ce n'est pas la première réforme
de la pac ait eu beaucoup de réformes de
la pac
d'abord pour absorber les différents
leviers agissements un choc considérable
lorsque l'espagne est entrée dans
l'union européenne puisque c'est un
grand producteur agricole et à des chocs
aussi considérable lorsque la pologne et
la hongrie qui bénéficie très largement
des soutiens de la potée laguiole
communes sont entrés la pologne et la
hongrie
comme les autres pays d'ailleurs
tiennent beaucoup à cette politique
agricole commune
parce que elle est un élément essentiel
de soutien au revenu de leurs
agriculteurs mais progressivement
évidemment on a évolué vers une
politique arrive une commune qui aide et
une aide à la production est pas à
l'entreprise et par conséquent les
grandes entreprises évidemment du coup
touche davantage que les petites
entreprises qui peut être en auraient le
plus besoin
est ce que la réforme de la pac peut
porter préjudice aux intérêts des
agriculteurs français
alors effectivement vous avez dit que
tout à l'heure que les ong et les verts
n'étaient pas contents et considère que
ce qui a été décidé en matière de
réformes qui d'ailleurs ne s'appliquera
que à partir du 1er janvier 2023 n'était
pas suffisant
il faut noter quand même que la fenps et
sera le grand syndicat agricole est
satisfait était satisfait déjà de la
proposition de la commission est
satisfait du compromis qui est intervenu
cette nuit à luxembourg alors bien sûr
la fen fnsea représente plutôt les
grandes entreprises productives et
rentables et peut-être moins les petites
entreprises qui sont dans la difficulté
d'ailleurs on note que d'autres
syndicats agricoles ont critiqué le fait
qu'il n'y ait pas un plafond dead par
entreprises ont critiqué aussi le fait
qu' il n'y ait pas suffisamment de
mesures en faveur de l'environnement et
ont bien sûr compte sur le parlement
européen qui prendra sa décision
vendredi
pour qu'il y ait un deuxième tour dans
cette négociation pour tenir compte de
l'avis du parlement européen en tout
état de cause tout ceci est assez limité
puisque le budget de l'union européenne
c'est 1% du pnb de l'union européenne en
gros et puisque on a dit tout à l'heure
que l'agriculture ça représentait la
politique agricole commune
un peu plus d'un tiers de ce budget ça
veut dire qu'avec en gros 0 35 % du pnb
de l'union européenne
on a beau on assure son autosuffisance
alimentaire et ses capacités
d'exportation mais ya encore beaucoup à
faire en matière de qualité en matière
de protection de la nature et en matière
d'environnement
merci beaucoup claude blanche maison
pour votre éclairage rappelle que vous
êtes expert en relations internationales